冠動脈バイパス術別名キャベッジは重度の肝動脈疾患の方が楽しん菌の血液循環を改善
するために実施されます
この処置では体の別の健康な場所の動脈や静脈を閉塞した冠動脈につなげるかあるいは
それらを移植します
移植された動脈や静脈は冠動脈の閉塞した部分を開始
真琴に酸素が豊富な血液を運搬します
1回の手術中に一つ以上の冠動脈をバイパスさせることもあります
手術前に点滴ラインを開始し鎮静薬が投与されます
きゃべっち処置は全身麻酔下で行われ鈴忠あなたが眠っています
呼吸チューブが口からなどに挿入され手術中の呼吸をしやすくします
尿を排出させるためにカテーテルを1本暴行に挿入します
冠動脈バイパス術は一般的に3時間から6時間かかります
従来のバイパス手術では額は胸骨を被っている皮膚を切開して開始します
続いて胸骨を切り心臓に到達するために胸郭を動かします
処置中は循環型は心肺バイパスポンプ
すなわち心肺装置に接続されています
この装置は手術中一時的に心臓と肺の機能を担い
り海外食塩を所定の位置に縫い付けている間
心臓を提出させることができます
にか車の欠陥のうち1か所を移植片に使用するのが普通です
それは胸部の内部胸骨動脈または足の伏在静脈です
内部胸骨動脈移植片では鎖骨下動脈に続いている上端部はそのままにして
下端部を胸壁から冠動脈へ閉塞部を超えて迂回させます
閉塞部を超えて
理解は次いで移植片を所定の位置に縫合します
伏在静脈移植片では理解は一方の端を大動脈と縫合しもう一方の端を閉塞部を超えて
狭まって動脈と縫合します
閉塞部を超えて移植片がしっかりと所定の位置に収まったことを確認し世界は電気振動
を使って心拍を復元し一時的なペースメーカーを心臓につけます
心臓が再び正常ニコ動するようになったら心肺装置を取り外します
英会話胸骨を元の位置に戻してワイヤーで固定し皮膚切開部を縫合して閉じます
一時的な廃液チューブが皮膚を通して切開部分の下に配置されます
きゃべっち処置に置いて他に二つのタイプが最近開発されました
それはオフポンプつまり新弟子を伴う人工心肺を用いないタイプと信州が最小のタイプ
のバイパスずつです
オフポンプキャベッジは後同バイパス移植術とも呼ばれています
というのは心臓が停止鈴心肺装置を使用しないか
のです代わって移植が行われる心臓の部分を安定させるための機械装置が使われます
世界は特別にデザインされた装置も胸部の小さい切開部
ポートから挿入し信州が最上のバイパス措置を実施します
これらの処置は時々心肺装置を必要とすることがあります
手術後集中治療室に運ばれます
心臓の活動が注意深くも2体されます
必要に応じてペーシングワイヤーを使用し一時的に心拍をコントロールします
胸部中文所定12時され過剰の出血と空気も境遇から排出します
自分で呼吸できるようになれば呼吸チューブ香取はず者で酸素マスクに交換されます
膀胱カテーテルは付けたままです
その後3日から4日間で回復するにした台すべての装置は徐々に取り外されます